I'm going to put into words what we've
just shown algebraically okay so if P of
X any polynomial you like is divided by
a monic linear divisor which means X
minus a okay if that guy is divided by X
minus a then the remainders theorem
States unsurprisingly the remainder is
what's it equal to have a look can I
find it it's pay off a whatever that
happens to be okay by the way using the
language that we already know we've
developed right from the beginning I can
say it's P of the zero of the divisor do
you see that a is the zero of this
polynomial here you put in a it's gone
okay so that's the remainder theorem
okay now my question to you is don't
write anything down just have a think
about this with me my question to you is
what if you tried this what if you put
in a number and your remainder happened
to be zero what does it mean when you
divide through something and you get all
the way to the end and your remainder is
exactly zero you know if there's no
remainder it's a factor right for
example if you took if you took seventy
right and then you divided it sorry you
divided it by five right you go okay
once five zero 2014 and then you go
again you're like four times five is 20
that's zero oh I've got no remainder
that means five is a factor of seventy
yeah so if I gone through this whole
process and the remainder was zero
I haven't found like this long statement
I've got a factorization I have a
factorization well we've spent a lot of
our life trying to find factorizations
so really the remainder theory is
actually just a stepping stone it's a
stepping stone to what I really want is
for this thing to be zero okay which is
this guy
this corollary it's called the factor
theorem so directly underneath here you
can make a new little something because
it ends up being the point really the
remainder theorem is not that useful
it's useful specifically we're in the
remainder is zero so the factor theorem
states if P of a equals zero in that
special case where you tried it out and
you're like tada
no remainder then X minus I didn't need
the bracket went up over there X minus a
is not just something I divided by its a
factor
hence back to theorem of P of X okay so
what's the remainder theorem say it says
if you want to find the remainder
quickly you don't have to go through the
entire division process just put in
substitute in the right number and then
you will get out the remainder tada
but where this is really most useful is
where the remainder you get happens to
be zero there's no remainder it's a
factor so let me give you an example of
this and we'll actually work through the
whole question okay
can you write this down I need more
space but I want you to write down the
question first so here's a polynomial P
of X so if this is the polynomial get we
get given up until this topic if you
were trying to do something with this
well I suppose you could differentiate
that'll give you some stationary points
that kind of thing but usually I need
like intercepts and that kind of
requires a factorization as a cubic I
don't know what to do with it until now
okay the factor theorem and the
remainder theorem along with it give us
a quick and relatively efficient way to
find out how to factorize this right
what I want to do is I'm just going to
throw numbers at it until this happens
okay now admittedly that is a bit like
that there's a randomness and time
consuming part to that which means that
we will craft like I've crafted and we
will craft polynomials for you such that
you're not throwing numbers at this
forever and I'm like oh I got to 100
tada I found it okay we'll make it
relatively easy to find but there is an
element of trial and error here okay so
here's the way we're going to begin
we're going to test a particular this is
me
buying out different things to see if I
can find a factor okay I'm gonna start
at 1 0 is kind of like a natural place
to stop but I don't need to test 0
because you can already tell me what P
of 0 is right P of 0 is 21 because all
this disappears you just get left with
the constant don't need to test that I'm
just gonna go straight to the next
smallest number okay let's see what
happens I get 1 plus 3 minus 25 plus 21
4 plus 21 that's 25 oh how convenient
it's zero now like I said before we will
craft this on purpose okay however you
might not get lucky the very first time
if you don't get one rather than going 1
2 3 4
I'd probably advise you go to negative 1
so you just want to stay nice and close
to the origin because smaller numbers
are just easier to deal with
okay so we got it on first go isn't that
nice but you would have to go further
and further out I don't think you will
ever find anything further than 3 and to
be honest in an exam you probably
wouldn't find anything further than 2
we're not trying to test your
perseverance we're trying to test your
ability to understand this sum theorem
okay I found this what does the factor
theorem tell me that that means
therefore what's a factor X minus 1 is a
factor okay I tested positive 1 but
that's a so this is my X minus a it's a
factor now when I know that it's a
factor I can actually divide through
right because if I divide through by
this what was it X cubed plus 3x squared
is that right okay just just see where
I'm going here right before we actually
go ahead and crunch this what do you
expect the answer to be up here what do
you expect there's going to be this is
dividing degree 3 by degree 1 so you
expecting a degree 2 with remainder 0
because that's what I just found out
you're going to end up with a quadratic
and you guys could do quadratic in your
sleep right so I've taken a question
which was insoluble before
and reduce that that's one which you're
quite comfortable with okay so let's
just go ahead and do the division first
things right up here x squared is how
many times I can fit X into X cubed I
will multiply that's a minus
okay now I'm going to subtract that
gives me 4 x squared
how many times is it go in plus 4 X now
I'll multiply back 4 x squared minus 4 X
watch out for the double triple whatever
negatives there are okay what is the
subtraction -21 am negative okay good
that look okay how many times does that
go in negative 21 and as a relief tada
we get our remainder as you are just
like we expected okay that's good from
here I can make this division statement
but my remainder 0 so therefore it's
actually a factorization I can say that
P of X is equal to X minus 1 x squared
plus 4x minus 21 bracket and I can
factorize this further right
what paradigm is am i searching for 7
and negative 3
yet negative 3 so that gives me X plus 7
X minus 3 now that you have a
factorization you can do everything you
need to like the follow-up question for
this would be graph you probably would
have have to go into here to find
stationary points and all that kind of
thing
but you're done does that make sense so
just to quickly review why don't we
establish all of this theory ok
it's basically so that we can start
tackling these because before if it
wasn't a quadratic you were stuffed
like you can't factorize okay but the
factor theorem tells you through some
numbers at that thing until you find a
remainder of 0 once you do that off you
go and you'll reduce it to a question
you can handle okay any questions yep
yep yep ah okay
good question this is gonna be so quick
and we've done all the hard work right
at home just quickly do it together draw
yourself a set of axes okay what's the
point of factorization well if I were
graphing y equals that then every time X
equals one of these zeros okay I will
get an x intercept right so from this I
read off that my x-intercepts are
negative seven one and three negative
seven let's put that guy over there and
one and three roughly okay negative
seven one three this is a cubic so it's
either going to go low to high or high
to low which one is it it's it's low to
high because which is the number that
this is a single number here that tells
me that's the case it has a name that's
how important it is it's the leading
coefficient yeah it's positive so that
means it's going to have this this
positive shape here I've got three
x-intercepts but I might as well while
it's easy find out what the y-intercept
is what is it it's great twenty-one
right now I'm not going to put paint
myself into a corner I'm just gonna draw
this shape and wherever I hit the y axis
I'm just going to make that twenty-one
right I'm rather than make a twenty-one
I then try and get there and then you
have to rub out in the larkin thing so
let's see I'm guessing something like
this tah-dah
I'm calling that twenty-one okay because
you know calculus because you know
calculus you can find and you pretty
much I expected to find those two
stationary points okay and just a bit of
a heads up for you
we can quickly differentiate this that's
P of X so where am i got space I have
space here
what's P - 3 x squared yo you can read
off when we write 3x squared plus 6x
minus 25
yeah yeah now when I have a look at that
no effect arises you jumps out at me as
a general rule if your x-intercepts are
nice numbers your stationery points will
be gross numbers okay or vice versa if
we've given you something so that the
stationary point is it easier to find
the armor routes will be disastrous to
find in fact some of the questions you
may have even noticed they say do not
attempt to find the x-intercepts okay
because remember I said to you
oh we crafted this so you'd find this
quickly right but many polynomials just
they don't even have integer roots at
all so you'll never guess because
they'll all be um weird square roots and
all that kind of thing and you can't you
know throw things that won't expect to
find those okay so yeah these stationary
points are going to be a little bit
worse you're gonna have to find use them
doing the quadratic formula but then you
can find those and they would these
would be subsequent parts of a later
question so that's why you'd spend some
time on it okay Zen answer your question
right off yep Maya do you mean when
we're doing this yeah fantastic
okay let's um let me restate that
question and see if you guys can help me
answer that okay a - question was when
doing this testing process is there more
than one that will give us this result
think think about this think about what
the factor theory says and you should be
able to its that question for me right
how many factors this is have it has
three so if you're some kind of um if
you're um if you're some kind of reader
who's like I just like the number seven
and let's just be negative just just for
the sake of it right well let's have a
look and see what happens and that's
going to be minus 343 first three lots
of 49 minus 25 lots of negative seven
plus 21 I'll put some money down that
that's zero right because look I've
already already found that it's going to
be a factor and of course if I had
tested three it would also give me a
factor what will then result of course
is that I will divide my original
polynomial by something different I will
divide through by like say X plus three
da-da-da-da-dah right so of course your
quotient will be different but
eventually we'll all factorize to get
this guy because that is
unique factorization make sense yeah but
of course you want to find the closest
one because small numbers are small
numbers are less gross than big numbers
okay happy